Vsauce Kevin here let's split a pizza
I'll eat one half and you eat the other
I'm gonna be using a laser guide and a
protractor to make sure that it's
perfectly mathematically equal so that
no one is complaining that one of us got
more pizza than the other one okay here
we go there we go all right let's just
get this cutting board out of the way
perfect these are two exactly equal
halves so grab your slices all right I
know that it doesn't look like it but we
can prove this mathematically but before
we do that let's analyze how pizzas are
traditionally cut and how pizzas can be
infinitely cut pizza is usually cut
right down the center through its
diameter and then cut again at a
90-degree angle perpendicular to the
first cut two more cuts bisect each 90
to a 45 to make 8 equal slices that B's
for people or to people equally and
maybe three if one of them just isn't as
hungry but what about cutting one pizza
to feed 13 people or 31 slices won't
work
we need mono he drawled disc tiles by
cutting the pizza into a pinwheel you
can get 12 identically shaped wedges
mono he'd roll tiling means every tile
is the same shape in 2015 mathematicians
Joel Hanley and Steven Worsley found you
can create infinite families of mono
hydral discs tilings by sub tiling
forever the actual math proofs on this
get rather complicated but basically
there's no mathematical end to the
pattern of pizza wedges that you could
make but obviously dividing up a real
pizza this way for little Billy's
birthday would be impractical the pizza
that I cut however is the same exact
method pizzerias used every day I just
moved the center divisors of a circle
was a problem proposed by LJ Upton in
1967 and solved in volume 41 of
mathematics magazine challenging readers
to show that alternating divisions of
circle with four lines converging on
concurrent point o and up to half of the
circle Michael Goldberg solved Upton's
problem without using calculus in 1994 a
follow-up piece in mathematics magazine
explained how this problem demonstrates
a fair way to split up pizza and the
pizza theorem was born if a pizza is
divided into eight slices by making cuts
at 45-degree angles from any point in
the pizza then the sums of the areas of
alternate slices are equal that's why if
we top alternating slices with green and
yellow peppers it becomes clear we have
two equal halves we can do the math but
a proof without words is considered by
many to be the highest most elegant form
of proof and our proof is in the pizza
we'll label our pizza slices a through H
and that will represent each slice as to
equal shapes will clone the four smaller
slices while the four larger ones will
be reduced to make up for that
duplication they'll be weird shapes but
they'll be equal we'll label them with a
capital letter in a lowercase letter to
differentiate which slices yours and
which slice is mine so here's a here's B
this is C d e f g and finally H so the
large slices G H a and B are divided
into two equal wedges and the small
slices Fe D and C are duplicated within
the pizza proving that we split our
original pizza perfectly for two people
this will work regardless of the
concurrent point on the disc or pizza
here's a wonderful proof without words
visualizer created by Kristian Lawson
perfect where you can move the interior
point and instantly see the different
slices that fulfill the pizza theorem
the most delicious theorem of all time
what began as an obscure math problem
dividing a circle in mathematics
magazine has continued to be refined and
reimagined 50 years later
is impressive no matter how you slice it
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
this pizzas three days old
[Music]